the book is crisis of command which just
came out September 6th how we lost trust
and confidence in American generals and
politicians when you were calling out
the leaders you know you know specific
leaders that you could have said you
know that person had responsibility in
this because there's a lot of people
that you during that time it was it's
Biden's fault how can you just pull it
in come out and you know it's it's
president's fault he's the
commander-in-chief he's the one that
screwed up here well no it's the
General's fault the general should have
given a better report no it is Biden's
fault no it's the people in the you know
who were actually there that didn't
properly report or no it's the prior
Administration everybody blames
everybody right
for from your perspective from your
point of view as an o5 who was in it who
knows the climate who knows how not to
leave who knows that others are talking
about us regularly everybody knows we're
eventually leaving Afghanistan who does
the buck stop with you know if you have
to say this person first then this
person then that person who would those
names be
yeah so I absolutely think President
Biden made some bad decisions but
when I went through my ordeal I never
actually used the word president use the
word Biden and every headline you read
about me said Lieutenant Colonel
scheller criticizes President Biden's
botched Afghanistan withdrawal never
used President Biden's name my wrath
during my ordeal was on the military
professionals and so where we're losing
Wars right now politicians are outlining
objectives so it's political objectives
that we're using violence to try to
compel an enemy to do something and
right now our general officers are not
being held accountable to that and
there's a lot of reasons why one of the
biggest ones is they rotate out every
two years and you can't accomplish the
goals within the time frame of their
little tours and so it's like well if
none of us are accountable
um you know if if one of us can't see it
from start to end then no one's really
accountable and so my position was in
April and I can go through the list real
quick in April 1 2021 President Biden
ordered a withdrawal of military forces
from Afghanistan and the theater
Commander at the time was a guy named
General McKenzie my opinion is General
McKenzie should have pushed back and and
not allowed that to happen now General
McKenzie and his Congressional testimony
has said that he disagreed with the
president's order and he said as much
through secretary Austin but the
president said no this is what we're
going to do so there's a moral case
study right there so people often say
well if you're the general you have to
follow the orders well there's
historical case studies if you go back
to Carter's presidency there was a guy
named singlob
s-i-n-g-l-a-u-b and he was the commander
of all forces in Korea and it's like the
same situation Carter and Biden a lot of
similarities and Carter said I want you
to pull all American forces out of Korea
and sing Labs like if you do that the
Koreans will all go to war that whole
Korean War we had it'll all be for
naught and Carter said I heard you out
but this is what we're doing and then
singlab went public with this
disagreement with Carter and he
ultimately changed the course of those
events right so we don't make generals
like that anymore so McKenzie could have
done that he chose not to right
secondly we not only are we evacuating
military forces before we evacuate
American citizens no-brainer but we
decide to do it from April to September
anyone that served in Afghanistan knows
that Taliban hides in the mountains in
the winter that's why we have what we
call a Spring fighting season so we
could have conducted the withdrawal from
October to March and been completely
uncontested but we did it in the peak
fighting season because the pr date of
September 11th was more important than
American lives and American Treasures so
there's like two huge mistakes that I
saw play out real time as I'm watching
this
and then the third week so this is
information that I've got later the
military investigation that was
presented to Biden I think the guy the
reporter's name was like Lester Holt
Luke Holt something like that yeah so he
asked President Biden hey the military
investigation what do you think about it
President Biden's that I reject it and
so then he came back and he tried to ask
like an intelligent follow-up question
like what parts do you disagree with and
he just said again I reject it and
that's the only thing we've gotten from
the president on that investigation well
that investigation was sent to me by a
disgruntled staff officer and in the
investigation it lays out that General
McKenzie's planner so when he was doing
the withdrawal starting one April he
assigned a separate General officer to
plan the evacuation so in DC they're
planning a be prepared to evacuation
separate Mission those planners planned
on using Bagram all the way until the
third week of June when unexpectedly
then General McKenzie ordered them to
pull Bagram off the off the table Bagram
was the key piece of train that we
needed the planners even when you read
the investigation don't understand why
he made that decision General McKenzie
and his Congressional testimony later
said because 650 troops wasn't enough to
hold the embassy and the H Kaya Airfield
right next to the Embassy and so he
decided to pull off pogram well so the
next week we we abandoned Bagram a month
later 10 August the Taliban walks in
finds 7 000 prisoners I mean that's more
than we responded to in the entire Kabul
disaster and that's not even counting
the Taliban Force right so then those 7
000 all the Taliban walk up to Kabul now
it's 15 August this is when General
McKenzie realizes his plan is falling
apart he throws 5 000 troops in addition
to the 650 at Kabul so two Marine
battalions in the 82nd they clash with
the Taliban the Marines have confirmed
now that they killed you know five to
six at least Taliban fighters that's
never reported
then that same day General McKenzie
orders them to stand post with the
people they just killed calls them a
critical external partner they obviously
allow the suicide bomber to go through
the checkpoint probably came from the
prison kills the 13 service members
injures 20 more kills hundreds of Afghan
civilians in the gate in response we
conduct a drone strike kill nothing but
women and children and then we stand
there and called an overwhelming success
I mean there is no better list of just
poor decisions that were made and so
yeah the junior enlisted service member
standing on the wall grabbing babies
over barbed wire is doing everything can
he's not thinking about politics and I
got all that but no one is going back
and saying hey the decisions that were
made between the National Security
Council and the four-star general put
our service members in a terrible
position and there was plenty of
off-ramps and preventable ways to do
this better
such as
well I mean you could just go through it
obviously and the reason why I asked
this is the following here's here's what
I asked let's just say all of a sudden
you know in business somebody's making a
bad decision at the top right and it's a
big business not a small business
Afghanistan is not a small business it's
a big business meaning we put a lot of
money into it we didn't put 10 million
100 million a billion dollars we put
real money into Afghanistan some are
saying the trillion some are saying
three trillion that's a lot of money
that we put into this thing that's a big
investment
so when something like that happens and
people are fully vested their lives
their friends have died they've seen
crisis they've seen issues you've
witnessed stuff that stuff's going to be
with you until they do that you die you
can't get that out of you right so
you're emotionally vested you're TR to
an average person's like what are you
guys complaining about it's just we're
out it's done it's over why are you
still complaining about it what are you
talking about you weren't there seeing
what's a sacrifice we were paying
was there was there hardcore arguments
on the back end disagreements fight
saying what the hell are we doing who's
agreeing to this was there anybody
courageous enough to go to McKinsey and
say why are you making this decision why
are we going were there any stories like
that that we're not aware of no not that
I know of how is that even possible
that's exactly right I mean that's why I
made the video because I felt exactly
what we're talking about now no one's
having these conversations and it's
crazy it really it was just quite I
couldn't fathom the the list of
decisions that were made and you know
I've had some staff officers that wrote
some of the operational plans and and
they told me that Bagram was always part
of the plans but the National Security
Council rejected it right and so you
know they're not all dumb people but
it's just the way these decisions were
made without pushback was really my
whole contention from that first video
it's okay so we we've had multiple
people that I've talked about how
different we could have done it you gave
one of them we could have waited a
little bit because the season would have
been better if we would have gone
October to March instead of you know
because they're trained for that uh you
know but they wanted to do a PR stunt
because of 911 so they didn't want to
wait that long they wanted to get it
done what other things could we have
done differently well the the no-brainer
is we should have just held on to Bagram
and maintained air support within the
country I mean for for decades that
would have been so easy to do that's
what we still do in Korea and we've got
hundreds of thousands still across
Europe from World War II I mean that
that was the no-brainer with a thousand
people you could have held Bagram and
you could have had this huge air
presence and that's what we've been
doing for the last five years I mean
people don't really like it's not like
the wars of 2009 through 12. I mean
really for the last five years all we've
done is provide air support uh for our
Afghan National partners and so the
decision to pull that I mean I just it
was hard for me to wrap my brain around
it Stu most of us saw this clip yeah
this clip went viral you know to and
then you hear people saying well you
know it's not really this it's Photoshop
it's it's from another time it's this
it's Dad you guys don't know what you're
talking about why are you guys spreading
conspiracy theories what what can you
tell us from personal experience of what
this this image this picture this video
that we all saw represents yeah I mean
that's real
um some of those Pilots so imagine a 03
uh a mid-20s Air Force pilot in that
plane right now and he has to make
decisions of whether he's going to kill
three yeah young guys right so like
that's not talked about think about the
20 year old pilot that has to make
decisions to either stop the plane or
keep driving and kill potentially all
those people holding onto the plane and
they were afraid that if they stopped
the plane the plane was going to get
overrun and destroyed and so that poor
guy had to make the decision to
essentially kill people to take off and
who were those people what were they
looking to do so this is the um H Kaya
Airfield so this is we made the decision
to to basically drop down to two two
spots the embassy in hkaya Airfield and
then eventually we evacuated the embassy
and now we're just operating out of this
place this place was just not easily
defended it had like 13 14 checkpoints
and what happened was on 15 August when
the Taliban rolled up they pushed all of
the civilians into the Airfield and kind
of used them as cover when they were
getting into firefights and so when they
pushed all the civilians on the Airfield
this is right when the Americans were
also responding didn't have their act
together this was the chaos that ensued
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here